Одна українська"Мрія" вражає світ у небі.
А друга українська "Мрія" - точна копія першої -
стоїть на землі. АН-225
під номером01-02 тридцять років тому
будувався одночасноз бортом номер01-01.
Ось це пілотська кабіна - вид знизу. Й усі агрегати для керування
і не тільки знаходяться в цьому місці.
Коли я проектував свої механізми,
я їх за розмірами мав "вписати" у розміри каркасу.
Нині Микола Калашніков провідний конструктор "Мрії".
А у вісімдесяті роки минулого століття
він був серед сотень інженерів з усього СРСР,
кі втілювали амбітний проект для космічної галузі.
. Будівництво другої "Мрії" призупинилося майже
одразу після першого польоту  літака номер один
і після розвалу СРСР вже ніколи не відновлювалось.
А все, чим була нашпигована друга "Мрія",
потроху мігрувало в середину першої
та інших вантажних літаків - "Русланів".
Рампу забрали на "Руслан". Тут був носовий обтічник.
Теж забрали на "Руслан". Це літак-донор. Наш годувальник.
У СРСР не планували виводити "Мрію" в серійне виробництво.
Максимум три літаки. Тож, усе для "Мрії" робилося
за ексклюзивними проектами на підприємствах різних республік СРСР,
і запасів деталей та агрегатів на ДП "Антонов" майже немає.
Ось ці шини колись в одиничних екземплярах виробляв Ярославль.
Як тільки до п’ятого корду шина стирається - одразу викидається.
Десь різко загальмували, і бетон з’їв
Втім, шини може виробити і британська фірма Данлоп.
Більшість з того, що є в "Мрії",
на території України виробити неможливо.
Якщо підприємства, які створювалися у СРСР під "Мрію"й існують,
то знаходяться вони переважно в Росії.
Ідея добудови другої "Мрії" наразі існує лише в теоретичному вигляді.
Адже за попередніми розрахунками "Антонова",
"Мрія-2" з урахуванням сучасних стандартів, а краще ще і майбутніх,
може коштувати понад півмільярда доларів.
Цей літак дуже хотіло придбати Міноборони РФ
7 років тому ще до початку агресії Росії проти України.
Минулого року з’явилися ще одні потенційні інвестори - з Китаю.
Каркасїм не потрібен. Вони хочуть, аби ми добудували це все,
а потім віддали їм усю документацію
в  електронному вигляді - щодо літака і технологій.
Щоб вони на цій базі, як-то кажуть, можливо,
навіть серійне виробництво могли б відкрити.
Договір про наміри наразі залишається лише договором про наміри.
Адже головне питання у будь-якого інвестора, каже Калашніков,
про те, який комерційний зиск може мати цей ексклюзивний літак.
По всьому світу не так багато замовлень
на перевезення надважких моновантажів,
і "Мрія-1"часто простоює, хоча зі своїх нечастих польотів
годує усе підприємство "Антонов".
А її, у свою чергу, поки ще може "годувати" деталями  "Мрія-2".
Швидше за все, вважає Микола Калашніков,
борт01-02може так ніколи і не піднятися в небо.
Принаймні, у держави немає таких амбітних планів.
Тож, для Миколи Калашнікова друга "Мрія"
так і залишається мрією нереалізованою.